hello and welcome to maths implied in
this video we are going to learn about a
cool new trick to remember the urea
cycle
who urea cycle is a biochemical pathway
that runs in a body and does the main
job of converting ammonia to urea
guys before watching this video make
sure you have seen the video about urea
cycle on our channel to have a complete
understanding about this topic
so this is the urea cycle this is a
biochemical cycle that operates in both
mitochondria as well as the cytoplasm of
the cell and performs the main job of
converting toxic ammonia to urea as you
can see in the cycle it has some key
molecules that are used in this pathway
which are shown in the orange color and
it also has all the enzymes that
catalyze these reactions which are shown
in gray color with dashed out lines
first let's try to memorize all the
intermediate molecules of urea cycle and
then we will take a look at a mnemonic
that will help us to remember all the
enzymes of the urea cycle as well so
let's start with our first mnemonic and
for this mnemonic listen to the story
once upon a time you left your home for
college and on your way to college you
saw an orange colored cat this cat was
very strange as soon as you got close
you are able to hear what that cat was
saying and she said I want an awesome
umbrella what a stupid story but that
brings us to our first mnemonic which is
orange colored cats always asked for
awesome umbrellas
in this mnemonic the all in the orange
stands for ornithine which is this
molecule right here the C in colored
stands for carbamoyl phosphate which is
this molecule here formed by the
combination of ammonia with carbon
dioxide the C in Katz stands for our
next molecule which is the citrulline
citrulline is formed by the combination
of carbamoyl phosphate with ornithine
the e in always stands for aspartate
which is this amino acid here which gets
combined with citrulline
the a in ask stands for
argininosuccinate which is this molecule
here formed by the combination of
aspartate with citrulline the F in 4
stands for fumarate which is this
molecule right here which is formed by
the cleavage of arginine or succinate
the a in awesome stands for arginine
which is the next molecule in the urea
cycle the you in umbrellas stands for
urea which is the final product that is
produced in the urea cycle this mnemonic
pretty much covers all the intermediate
molecules of urea cycle but remember
guys if you don't have a conceptual
knowledge of urea cycle there is no
point in cramming all these names next
let's take a look at our second mnemonic
that will help us to memorize all the
enzymes that are involved in the urea
cycle and for this listen to this stupid
story first so you are at a party with
your family and you are sitting with
your brother suddenly you see some of
your aunts join the party and they were
very interested in throwing darts at the
dartboard but not even a single dot
thrown by your aunts hit the board so
you laughed and said to your brother can
your aunts aim accurately this brings us
to our second mnemonic of urea cycle
can our aunt aim accurately the C in can
stands for thermal phosphate synthetase
1 which is this enzyme right here and
this does the job of combining ammonia
with carbon dioxide and least the
formation of carbamoyl phosphate
the oh in R stands for ornithine
transcarbamylase this is the enzyme
right here that is involved in the
combination of or Athene and carbamoyl
phosphate leading to the formation of
citrulline the E in ants stands for
argininosuccinate synthetase this enzyme
is located right here and this does the
job of combining aspartate with
citrulline to form the argininosuccinate
the E in M stands for our next enzyme
which is the argininosuccinate lyase
this enzyme breaks down arginine or
succinate into fumarate and arginine the
e inaccurately stands for our next
enzyme which is our genus our genus is
the enzyme which splits arginine into
urea and ornithine so these were the two
mnemonics that will help you to remember
the intermediate molecules as well as
the enzymes that are involved in the
urea cycle thank you so much for
watching if you want all the flashcards
and the lecture handouts from this video
and all of the previous videos on
youtube make sure to join our channel by
clicking the join button below you can
also join our community at patreon.com
and get all these benefits plus
behind-the-scenes of these videos early
notifications and much more thank you so
much for watching